Richard Haass the president of the
Council on Foreign Relations joins us to
discuss the high stakes of president
Trump's Asia visit Richard good morning
you've worked in the State Department
for in multiple administrations
how is what's going on this chaos in the
State Department affecting foreign
policy the short answer is it's bad at
both ends of the process in terms of the
advice that the president the Secretary
of State are not getting and then
secondly when it comes to implementation
the fact that we're in presidents
heading off to Seoul North Korea is the
centerpiece of the visit we don't have
an ambassador there we don't have the
access to the government there that we
need we don't get the advice we need
this is this is a self-inflicted wound
that an own-goal as they say
yeah and how detrimental is that when as
you're heading out it's not a ringing
endorsement for your secretary of state
to say we'll see it's been my experience
when you're told that that means he
ain't gonna be here long and it's not
the first time this has happened the
Secretary of State was recently meeting
in China with his counterparts the
president was tweeting away that stop
wasting your time diplomacy is going
nowhere
it puts him in an impossible situation
and it's not just about Rex Tillerson
it's about who comes after Rex Tillerson
if the president isn't determined to
make sure his Secretary of State will
succeed the Secretary of State can't
succeed just focus on personal no
personnel let's focus on policy because
this is a really significant trip to
Asia where do you see as some of the
most important things he can accomplish
well the two big issues are North Korea
to see if you can get a common front
with China South Korea Japan to put
greater pressure on North Korea to the
point that will actually make a
difference
the second big issue is trade presidents
got five starts tops trade will figure
prominently in each one and it's really
the United States that's out of sync
remember the first big foreign policy
decision of this President was what to
yank the United States out of the
trans-pacific partnership so we are
completely out of sync with our allies
and potentially we could be in something
of a trade confrontation with China so
in a week that should have been about
preparing for this trip you had the
mower investigation the indictments
coming down does this cloud what the
president is trying to do well it
doesn't have it doesn't help obviously
but the locals there they're used to
dealing with American presidents under
pressure they had Ronald Reagan during
iran-contra Bill Clinton during the
impeachment so they said this is not not
fundamentally
new and obviously Nixon but it could be
a distraction in some ways for this
president and it's it's a backdrop you
don't need life's tough enough in Asia
particularly with North Korea this is a
country that's months or at most a year
away from having nuclear weapons they
can put on missiles that will reach the
United States we don't need any
distractions so when your initiative
success look like for this trip two
things would be the avoidance of a real
trade war I think that's the most you
could hope for the idea that we would
actually reenter the trans-pacific
partnership ain't going to happen it
would be good but it won't happen
the real question though is can we get
more of a common front to put more
pressure on North Korea so it would make
a difference
that's where China comes in and quite
honestly I don't see it happening
China is unlikely not unable but
unlikely and unwilling to agree with us
to put the kind of pressure on North
Korea that would really make an
appreciable measurable difference so I
don't think you can get successful by
the way - we're hearing - that the
president may meet with Putin on this
trip in the Philippines North Korea the
White House wants to put pressure on
North Korea for these oil and gas
shipments that are going into North
Korea right and Russia has become
something again a spoiler Russia votes
for sanctions in the UN the same
afternoon it ships things to North Korea
in contravention of sanctions so it
would help to get Russia on board China
on board more than they are but they're
not going to do enough to really decide
things quickly the National Security
Advisor HR McMaster saying that the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
is the only acceptable outcome I see
that is a really unhelpful comment it's
obviously a desirable outcome not going
to happen are we willing to accept some
lesser interim stages if not then we are
basically saying we don't believe in
diplomacy which either means we live
with the North Korea that can threaten
us or we go to war I do not understand
why we are not embracing more modest
diplomatic outcomes a lot of things
people don't understand but we're all
watching we'll see what happens thank
you very much Richard Haass